Nick Carter welcomes his first son ET  can exclusively confirmed that the  Backstreet Boy singer and his wife  Lauren KITT welcomed their first baby  together on April nineteenth around 11pm  his name is Odin rain Carter in German  mythology Odin is a widely revered God  earlier this month the couple tees their  son's name to ET is it something  sentimental put it this way it's a very  strong name and something like et has  learned that Lauren wasn't 30 hours of  labor she delivered the baby via an  at-home water birth the couple couldn't  stop gushing to ET / what each other  would be like his parents earlier this  month what are you guys most excited to  see in each other just this  unconditional love that he can give to  his son and the son can give to him and  the family that we just always wanted  she's the reason why I I felt  comfortable because I knew that she  would be the perfect mother and she  would be able to help me teach our child  all the things that he needs to learn